[Music]
hot boy I'd like pod boy to answer
something for me because I'm wondering
if they try to [ __ ] with him because I
went to his channel and popboy's been
great because he's the one that's been
mining all of the old Tiger belly stuff
and kalila stuff for Content because up
until very recently they weren't as
popular so a lot of weird stuff went
under the radar
but for whatever reason
all the videos on popboy's channel are
kind of a lot of them disappeared and I
don't know if they were copy struck or
whatever
um I also have a question from pod boy
what is your name and address no don't
do that I want you I want to dox you
not many people know that merch is crazy
now many people know that mercia's
Christian name is BET pixels it's true
it's that's that's bent pixels I'm
actually Ben pixels Junior but yeah your
father your father your father was
Benjamin pixels yeah that's the thing we
have um different uh middle names so I
don't have to use the Junior got it
that's fair enough okay I'm bent
Reginald pick oh bent our pixels and
he's bent David bent D pixels yeah of
course of course
um so this is why I'm wondering what
happened because pod boy put this in the
front of his video now the following
video is not my work it was uploaded on
Reddit uh it was uploaded on a Reddit
site that was recently taken down by
tigerbelly LLC so they taking down
Reddit sites
well I never said that
oh God why did I say that oh God what
this is where I'm gonna expose you in
two seconds what a loving relationship
they have yeah they're such lovely
people all of them imagine if like Mercy
you you go struggling out with a new
girl and we're hanging out and out of
nowhere she just goes in the middle of
dinner I'm gonna expose you right now
I'm gonna expose you right now I'd look
at him and I go oh boy what's going on
here
what flavor today Marsha I'm doing in
the C4 Skittles what do we got what are
we rocking I had to go to the store for
this is tropical mango it's not bad I
just try one of them it's not bad pretty
bad pretty good yeah I have no idea what
you mean by that
okay you want to be exposed yeah I'll
expose me yeah I love exposure
I'm hitting indoors I want to be exposed
okay
oftentimes in this podcast oftentimes in
this podcast
I will take what you've said and make it
my own because it's a little bit too
inflammatory
so you're stealing his stuff and you're
pcing it up for him
what are you his personal sensor
for the new way no it's a little bit too
inflammatory oh [ __ ] yeah it's a little
too inflammatory for you to say
that's right Bobby you listen to what
mommy tells you right yeah yeah like I
know okay oh see you want me to expose
you or not well you can't expose [ __ ]
that like I said to her on the side
that's like completely like private I
could expose you right now you have sex
with other boys no no no no no no not
analy not anal intercourse did you kiss
other boys pee pees
so you did I had a dude I can't say his
name yeah Brian Callan
this was a Lover's spat this was a
Lover's spat the whole time it's all
started yeah but say his name no there's
no way Tony Tony let's just call Tony
hinchclift
Tony Tony Tony
uh we'd be at a party I'm not gonna tell
you which Tony this is but he was on a
show called The Opie and redacted show
hahaha
and he would just go come here look I'm
not gonna say which tone it is but let's
just say he was the boss in our bedroom
I'm not going to say what Tony I'm gonna
say what Tony it is but he played for
the Bulls Tony cucoach did you suck Tony
cuckoo's dick
that would be surprising 14. okay I'll
be drunk okay I mean come here and you
just go behind a tree and make him he'd
make me blow him
would just grab your head he made you
make you blow him what if you hold your
nose
yeah just a buddy thing yeah yeah I was
shooting a movie in Thailand and I I had
sex with a couple of profits to his
regular ones but one night I would I
want you to I want to point something
out here this must have been during the
covid thing because he has a mask
underneath his chin and look at the glow
he's wearing plastic gloves
oh
stay in the mood you know imagine
telling a story about having sex with
two Thai prostitutes but being afraid of
a flu
it really is like a it's weird it's so
weird I know you know how you get in the
mood sometimes well for what that's an
ice cream for a walk no I just woke up
with a tingling sensation you're in a
mood and I am gonna go down to the
[ __ ] town oh
I've never been in a mood to go down to
[ __ ] town
Thailand is all [ __ ] town
that's still one of the only places in
the world where you have to go do you
guys have regular prostitutes here
found well no you can't say that because
ladyboys are regular prostitutes there
yeah I was about to say like we already
knew you were in the [ __ ] mood you
just told us you were [ __ ] two Thai
prostitutes
and what happens is it's I don't know if
you've been to Tijuana I've been to
Tijuana multiple times yeah where the
kids come out of nowhere kids
[ __ ] Thailand right they were like
when they run up you in Tijuana try to
sell you that just speak to them in
Spanish and they leave you alone
suck your dick in Easter and they were
coming out of nowhere right and I had to
like wait are you saying that you were
surrounded by a bunch of I hope of age
lady boys like some sort of World War Z
with zombies trying to suck your little
egg roll yes Royce they were of age I
don't know I know I said I said
hopefully of it I don't know I know you
said hopefully and I'm like yeah not
making any inflammatory comments because
I do not want to lose my channel over
Bobby Lee I don't want to make it any
prostate any Thai prostitutes worst day
at work ever
she said kids
wait did he oh my God oh my God hold on
wanna I've been to Tijuana multiple
times yeah where the kids come out of
nowhere
I need money right but you can [ __ ]
Thailand right they were like Easter
I'll suck your dick but are they still
kids who you this story you should have
done you should have but he's saying
he's like in Mexico kids come up to you
and ask for Chiclets but in Thailand
they want to suck your dick that's
literally there's no reason to say kids
in the first place unless you're
comparing Kids In America prostitutes
suck your dick like this
but in Thailand they go Meester Meester
I'm five
Meester Meester
which is a great band they're from
Thailand
you killed the mister mister lady
Easter and they were coming out of
nowhere right and I had to like you know
I mean [ __ ] out of here let me see you
know I mean
let me see your dick
for some reason
I was just like I can't I can't take
that extra stuff the [ __ ] thing I'm
okay with as long as they're of age
foreign
okay with as long as they're of age
you are oh God I don't want to do it
that pause was weird huh that was I
didn't notice it because I was I thought
you were reacting to what he said no
here this is this is real time look at
this it's like I can't I can't take that
extra step the [ __ ] thing I'm okay
with as long as they're of age
you are it's weird right so if I don't
want to do it if I told you yeah that
that's my thing ladyboys you wouldn't
look down on me or make fun of me in
that way no I've supported you our
entire friendship with a lot of weird
[ __ ] I wouldn't look down on you at all
yeah that feels good not even a little
bit if it was of age I got a big problem
with the kids thing that's
I like you know what no he's but I give
him credit he is smart because he said I
support you but he had to be very clear
like oh but listen to me
of age though don't don't brat me in
anything else if he does something it's
so weird why do you keep pointing at me
and saying kids I've never [ __ ] a kid
before I'm just you did you admitted to
it on Opie and Anthony
saying she keeps nodding off that yeah
there's a lot of ladyboys that are
little kids there's a lot of kids yeah
no kids did you ID them all
she literally called them kids
and you and I would be in a foxhole
probably yep right I'd probably show you
my thing yeah because that's Foxhole
that's what they called the [ __ ]
death slot they put Mad TV in in its
final [ __ ] season a foxhole
yeah you're gonna be on at like 4 a.m on
Sundays now wait what
I want to show you what it looks like
when it's super scared but that's what
that's not what it was in the spa you
wait wait wait
because you're gonna [ __ ] out or what
and I was like
I was like all right and so you know you
know can I say something man we've been
covering this for a while and for a bit
you know at the beginning you do start I
started feeling a little bit bad for
Bobby because the collyla stuff but this
guy's a [ __ ] these guys are all
weirdos like they all deserve each other
out there all you people deserve each
other are you [ __ ] weird [ __ ] I
don't know what this is all this therapy
like it must suck if you think about if
you're somebody that's actually a really
good comic but you happen to be born in
LA and then you're [ __ ] you know
like what do you do do you move to New
York like I mean this is like
I don't think you could fix the LA
comedy scene to be honest with you I
think I don't think you could fix La it
did period period at the end of that
sentence yeah
yeah the only one who can fix Los
Angeles is North Korea